OK.
I have what could be some optimistic news
for you.
We talked.
Optimistic vaccine news.
Now let's talk about therapeutics.
This may be optimistic and you'll see why
in a moment.
Des Deveare is one of the drugs that I told
you about six weeks ago as a candidate for
treating Corona virus.
And there are some very good results that
have been summarized in an actual our C.T.
randomly controlled trial with a placebo.
And I want to walk through it with you in
detail and tell you all the good things first.
Then I'll tell you why there is still some
skepticism that is warranted here.
Six weeks ago, I told you about a number of
drugs that were being tested.
Of course, there was Donald Trump's darling
chloroquine.
That was one recent results on those tests.
Not good.
Rum Desi Vier from Gilli Add Sciences is another
one for VVIP of also known as AB again is
being tested.
There's a combination of two HIV drugs being
tested.
There's a long list.
The room des of your trial has just bit one.
One room des of your trial has just been done
and it's been done correctly.
And this will help us to illustrate the difference
between a proper trial and one that is not
quite so good.
Donald Trump, you might remember, prop praised
the trial of chloroquine because it worked
really well.
He said now that had a sample size of under
40 people, very, very small sample size.
There was no control group.
There was no placebo group.
And it was not randomized.
Those are problems.
Now, momentarily, I'm going to explain to
you why each of those things matter.
We have a new study called Adaptive Cauvin
19 Treatment Trial or ACT.
It was randomized and it also had a placebo
group.
So here's what this test found.
First of all, it had 100 1063 patients.
Good sample size.
Thirty eight people in the other chloroquine
trial.
Not good.
Number two, it was randomized.
This is so important because if you don't
randomize who gets the treatment versus who
gets the placebo, placebo versus who's in
the control group, you could on purpose or
right.
Depending on what you want to attribute malice
or ignorance or just bias, you could on purpose
or accidentally test the drug on the patients
that are more likely to survive anyway.
And then you get very skewed results.
So randomization is very, very important.
What was being tested was the as the variable
was how long does it take to recover from
the virus.
And what this test found is that those getting
room Desi Vier recovered 31 percent faster
than those given a placebo.
Now, this is why the placebo is so important.
If you don't have a placebo group, any improvement
from the drug could be because of placebo.
You want to be able to rule out placebo.
So to properly do this, you give some people
the drug.
You give some people a placebo and you compare
the results.
And people shouldn't know, of course, whether
they're getting the placebo or the real drug.
Very good.
That was done.
So these parameters, 1063 patients.
Thirty one percent better than placebo.
This gives a P value of under point zero zero
one.
Very important.
What the hell am I talking about?
What is a P value?
This is not trivial.
The P value tells you whether the results
are scientifically significant or whether
they could be the result of mere chance.
The lower the P value, the more likely that
our results actually reflect reflect the inputs.
And they're not just a coincidence.
Let me give you an example of a test I could
do, which would have a very high P value,
and you'll very quickly understand what I
mean by coincidence.
Imagine that you have a normal two sided coin.
It's got heads and it's got tails.
There are two possible outcomes.
Heads or tails.
If the coin is flipped fairly, meaning I'm
not kind of like dropping it, so I get heads
every time you understand, the more times
I flip a fair two sided coin, we would imagine
I would roughly get closer and closer to 50
percent heads and 50 percent tails.
Imagine that I got results after flipping
the coin four times.
We're all four times I got heads and it's
a fair coin.
OK, the p value for that study would be very,
very high.
And what that would tell us is it could be
coincidence.
The fact that you flipped a fair coin four
times and got heads for time and times in
a row would have a high p value because it
could just be chance and not representative
of what would be the long term expec expectation,
which is you only get heads half the time
and you get heads tails half the time.
So you would be very wrong if based on getting
heads four times, you made a big bet that
it would always be heads.
That means there's a very high p value there
in the study on room desert here.
We have a very low P value.
It's less than point zero zero one.
What that tells us is that it is incredibly
unlikely that the patients who did better
on the drug versus the placebo did better
only by chance.
Now, in addition to the quicker recovery,
31 percent faster recovery for people having
robbed as of year versus placebo, the mortality
rate was 8 percent for those who received
from Denvir and eleven point six percent for
those who received the placebo.
Now the P value there is point 0 5 9.
Basically point 0 6 in textbooks.
We are told a P value greater than point means
that the results are not statistically significant.
So the idea here is people who recover seem
to recover more quickly because of the drug,
and that's statistically significant.
It's less clear whether the drug helps people
survive who otherwise wouldn't.
But here's the thing about the .05 0.06 p
value.
There's nothing hard and fast about point
0 4 9 is significant and point 0 5 1 is not.
It's not a magical spot and there can be a
difference between statistically significant
and clinically significant.
So in either case we can speculate and this
is mere speculation, but it seems reasonable.
We could imagine this trial of a thousand
people was if people already quite ill.
What we would want to see is if you give the
drug earlier, does it increase survivability
to a greater degree?
Now, that's all the good news.
Take everything I just told you and realize
it may not be true.
What I mean by that is the following.
We don't actually have the data from the study
yet.
What we have is a summary of data done by
doctors.
It has happened in the past that the summary
sometimes you go and you look at the data
and you say the summary is wrong.
This is not actually what the data show.
If the data have been summarized accurately,
then we do have something here to look at.
Now, in the meantime, there's been a different
study of Ramdas severe with only a couple
of hundred people.
It was double blind placebo and it shows no
benefits from REM desert here.
So we still need more study.
If this this study is accurately representing
the data, that's very good.
Now, one other note on these tests.
One thing that gets difficult when you do
these tests, when you have an active pandemic,
is that if you suspect that you're testing
a drug that works, it's keeping people alive
who otherwise might die.
If that's happening, it very quickly becomes
a moral question of crap.
How long do we keep giving people the placebo?
If we might be able to save a lot of people
by giving them the real drug.
Now, we don't know that yet with room of.
My point is in these RC teas, you very quickly
will sometimes get an ethical dilemma when
you get an efficacy signal, when the drug
seems to be working very important and that's
something that's going to have to be discussed.
So this is how you do science, right?
You don't go on national TV and say, hey,
36 people in France did well.
Everybody, what what do you have to lose?
Maybe take some days of your prophylactically.
Right.
You don't go on Sean HANNITY on his program
and say, hey, a doctor is taking this and
zinc prophylactically and he's doing great.
This is how you actually do science.
And I'm glad it's been done.